well those hospitalizations are leading
to a local er doctor to say he's
admitted covet patients non-stop the
majority of them young and unvaccinated
the i-team's david charn is here now
with his message david well you may
remember dr kamran khan the i-team
introducing you to him earlier this year
he doesn't just save lives he also makes
music and right now he's using that
platform to urge young people to take
this wave of kovid very seriously
there's patients that are lining up in
the hallways right now coughing coming
in
and most of these patients are
unvaccinated emergency department doctor
kamran khan says he's seeing a spike in
covid patients their emergency room is
flooding in with covey patients every
day i've been working non-stop now i'm
on the front lines fighting what could
make you die khan is not only a
physician he's also a rapper taking to
twitter and instagram sounding the alarm
to his more than 130 thousand followers
we talked to him for a brief minute
while on a shift at mountain view
hospital monday they actually just call
me to go see two more patients that are
in the hallways right now in the
emergency room so i'm actually headed
there after this conversation with you
overall hospital admissions are down
from a peak a few weeks ago but it's
unclear if the duration of patients stay
because of the delta variant may be
causing an increase in the number of
patients still needing care people in
their 30s and 40s in the majority of
them unvaccinated i'm actually seeing a
lot of younger people that are getting
more sick this time around the latest
data from researchers at the university
of minnesota and reviewed by the i-team
show three valley hospitals were at or
above capacity for icu patients in the
last week of august henderson hospital
desert springs and sunrise in addition
centennial hills hospital reported more
than 100 percent of its hospital beds
occupied while mountain view reported 96
percent the best advice from khan get
vaccinated i'm not a preacher i'm not
telling you to do something you don't
want to do but i'm just basing it off of
what i see
now of course we want to point out that
these numbers should not prevent you
from seeking care in an emergency of
course go to the hospital and seek help
we did check in with the nevada hospital
association and mountain view today but
did not hear back of course it is the
labor day holiday hospitals nor the
association release this specific data
we just showed you but over the past
couple months the i-team has been
digging through those numbers that are
required to be reported to the federal
government i'm david charns 8 news now